n n
[Music]
nah
n
[Music]
can you guys hear me can you hear me
fine
how do I
sound
fine do I sound
great
wonderful
no no um King and Cog are on their
way I don't normally I wouldn't do a uh
a reaction by
myself yes there will be an adct show
tonight
Mighty mellow I see what you doing
there what are we expecting today I'm
keeping my expectations low I'm going be
real
you he was peeking in the background my
girl is
sick she don't feel that
good
yes show starts in seven
minutes they'll be here soon guys I just
sent the
reminder wait they heard me in the
background yes
that's torch the
line we ain't being destructive we're
not ARS
arson King is
here
all
right they can hear
you yeah we can go to
Twitch
all right let me go ahead and just
switch over now and just start fixing
this while we're waiting for the twitch
thing all right guys switching over
now my sound isn't reverbing is it no I
I hear you fine you sound fine talk
again so I make sure they hear you
all right so that one's going to be
Kings can you hear me fine
King did I mute myself before I left the
zoom yeah did can you hear me fine King
yeah I can hear you perfectly okay my
sound isn't reiring right no you sound
fine you sound
great
perfect perfect they need to hear
me you guys ain't gon you guys ain't G
to want to miss IOP this
[Laughter]
week oh my God I don't feel good today I
almost cancelled this
but I was like The Show Must Go On yes
adct The Show Must Go On I would have
did it by myself for what I know is
about to
happen
yeah what's going on yeah backto
back hey man heard these PlayStation
dudes got a secret show when it's going
to show I don't know but Xbox says we're
ready to
go bars with the general oh man yo I got
something that I'm GNA do cuz I know
it's going to be
disgusting crazy but King we're not
supposed to cap for games in a third
party a show is a show is a show is a
show you are
ridiculous where where where is it at is
it on Twitch or we do yeah we're doing
twitch all right got four minutes left
had to get get my fortnite in I was in a
heavy match pause I came in I came in
third I don't like how you said
that yeah like the kid from um Simpsons
yes yes just like him all right now uh
three three minutes
right what's your Countdown say m say
three minutes 3 minutes 36 seconds all
right cool let me get some out until
destruction
you're
crazy yeah that was it that was it that
was it I remember that
joke to get this work you about to get
this work work work I don't have a time
timer do you guys have a timer I have a
hell of a time or pause yeah M you want
me send you the link Twitch TV oh there
we go 3 minutes and 5 Seconds I had to
refresh all right cool yep we in the
same thing we in the same thing cool all
right Forte is supposed to show up but
Forte if he isn't here by the time it
starts I'm locking it down he's going to
lock it down there will be no further
entry
yeah the door is are how you he going to
put the rule in like the doors are it's
cuz I have to redo this thing oh you
doing boxes and stuff yeah yeah yeah
he's not trying to redo Bo day what's
the shirt of the day he Dragon Ball Z
all right okay got balls on your is
Dragon Ball Ball s not Dragon Balls
Dragon
Balls who's Dragon Balls ball a little
kid in this one little man I can't be
having little kids dragging balls P wow
you're the one that put that energy in
yeah he did he you got the shirt you you
w up you got the
shirt doing lot you was telling me what
was going on all right peace all right
cool I'm logging in my PC's slowing
down now I got to do everyone's again oh
so what should you do like boxes or
something yeah I have to do everyone
individually sound like lemon right now
yeah for these things it really it it
make it makes it pop more if I take that
extra time oh we live yeah we've been
live live live we live
live project Aries in the
building uh let me get my twitch stream
up video
up
this music is mad intense it's like a yo
it is
it this look at the look at the full
moon I told you dude it's going to be
horrible for you this month I told you
the month for shober is that a fact I
told you every week it was going to be a
punch in the
mouth I told you I told you but y'all be
thinking a the king is capping
oh it is a third party showcase now yeah
yeah but you know what what's crazy is
watch what they see what they about to
see you know what's funny on my screen I
have two so I can be like it's back to
back the
spin I don't care what it is it's a show
D ain't showing feel I feel that where
they at though all we get to see is CEOs
getting kicked
out
oh please not my favorite CEO hermit
Holtz no
please out of pocket soon there going to
be a whole different
face y hope y hope a portal open here on
your left it ain't have
happening we ever happening get that man
of Sho it's going on what's going on
troubles shoot gaming my means gang
gang I sent you an invite to a party
yesterday M what happened to you what
happened to you all right here you go we
starting up fly partner review he said
you can't take two gaming
addicts partner pre US Canada oh they
starting it
off Fight for Your Life shout out to
almost 800 people in the chat oh let's
go infinite wealth let's get to it let's
go oh
Sega that looks 60
frish MH I hope
frames like a
dragon two Heroes
together yes need a breather number
let's ride some Dolphins
pause what is he doing in Hawaii it's
going to be
hilarious yeah
too many Street punks getting you down
time for the getaway you deserve
Geto island is the destination for
you
yo oh you look at your
man the red D DIY lifestyle awaits this
is Game Pass yes gather material conf
yet roundings hey K forment
today buy unique Furniture snap this
like a mini game map what are we doing
or simply craft it
yourself
hilarious there we
go yeah yeah for building and watch as
your dream home unfolds just the way you
like got tigers in the building there we
go 14 in the building what up though
adic why would you send why you send the
link to my Gmail I'm like where's the Le
oh I'm just so used to emailing these
guys this in you can
customize I had to look on my phone to
see it oh okay we got we got yo this
looks crazy here we
go got to get the props
ready
get the Tomato your man with the
eyes hey yo kick David kick put me in
the game put me yo Phil down this
Maximus really expensive I told you I'll
make my debut we
outside it's said K yo somebody over
there oh you go here you go the
beef
get the dudes in a purple suit you'll
have to beat some sense into them to
preserve your Island Kingdom so is this
a this is a side mode
yeah you get to play with King in the
side
mode build it's just called play with
King
pause wash your
hands googly ass a your man I didn't
even see the green dude boy
he look freaky he got some bumps on his
hands I'm done
man that guy look wild with the why they
promoting this mode that's what I just
thought it was a weird choice to promote
this mode
yeah people go some people may think
this is the game like I'm like this is
not the game like this is no that's not
the game but it is fun though they got
King on it they just had to show me
first no game pass no Game Pass just
play not yet though yet but it will it
will I feel will come too I got to bet
with MD on that but like yeah it will
come soon oh more details oh here we go
oh this when you click the link you
click the click the link to find out he
hit me in the mouth and Game
Pass oh man uh oh Sho your L team
brought you power wash
velocity got love that power wash
man oh Thomas check this who that though
what's this Loki oh look at
me hey yo Hardcore
Parkour oh he got the Run game
on
that a he got crazy
followers punch you in the mouth like
that he the mouth punch
you
stylish slide up behind
you kind of reminds me of Fury
mhm look
cool he what EO will not die will not
die he
won't who is
EO Xbox series snx oh will not die
little
go down Little Ghost run little fury
yeah unlike Sony he will not
die oh W to deep this is that uh horror
game on the oil rig joint they showed
like a second this joint will look good
in PlayStation VR
too y'all please put some games in there
no man he would be too scared to play
this on the
VR hor games are different than y yeah
man horror games is
crazy how did this man find himself in
this situation yo you remember this this
look like Destiny remember that board on
Destiny yeah do the jump It's The Raid
right that was the raid um kind of what
is it like raed the machine VI a little
bit Yeah I think what the heck is going
on here he don't need to be on this all
rig by himself like this it looked like
that part in Destiny when they told you
to go to that that that planet that
underwater oh you talking about Titans
yeah Titan you talking about
Titans po the lck yeah yeah I ain't
popping no locks I'm not even going to
be there mhm well if you find yourself
no you don't find yourself if you go on
attender
date oh man you find yourself in a weird
position hold on hold on just hold on
hold oh man that water killing you mhm
you ain't making it back oh this look
man this look like some deep blue Seas
type stuff yeah they go for the horror
this for the horror hats you you know
what I'm saying something going pop out
something pop out wait for the shark we
got to find out what's on this oril rig
that got him oh you heard that yeah oh
oh oh no we out yeah we out here what
are you out to the next stre out we out
we getting in going you hear that you
hear that yeah what's
up oh no hell no oh wait a second we
hear people screaming Los talking about
he like it's real out here man it's real
out here what is going on oh wait I saw
something I saw
something oh no that was the reflection
of the water oh no you got to go in Merc
you got to swim in the doodle
water might need that might need that
screwdriver just went by sharks is
swimming in the
[Music]
water you know what sad this game's got
more you know what's sad a big brown
shark you know what's sad this game got
more attention and detail than uh
Spider-Man oh shut up that Spider-Man is
dope man it just got a lot of bugs a man
and it did something to a intrical
character that I
hated what it's black it's black
somebody closed it it's black who closed
the hatch somebody closed the
hatch yo how come they a show no monster
though now you know they got to hold
that that's the whole premise of the
game on that rig
the Big
B what's
this oh yes roll let's
go
Detroit blest game going that game when
I saw this movie as a
kid scared the hell out of me about
Detroit I thought Detroit was like that
for real I was like Detroit is like that
for Detroit is like that they was
murdering cops in the
beginning viciously I said oh it's my
daddy
Detroit yo this is so dope yo the
Carnage in this game is crazy yeah I'm
definitely can't wait for this So Co did
you really think there's a Robocop in
Detroit I just thought that look at her
face oh spot on perfect oh yeah that
look just like her let's go oh it looks
so good shoot the guy show me blow his
legs off pause I'm not playing any more
games after him
that this movie is a
classic all I know is when you shoot the
hand Cannon does the does the the Fire
come out of the sides of it the we need
to see the 209 yes see the 209 there we
go shall see it you have 5 Seconds to
you have seconds toly that was yo that
movie Scared yo I Forte that movie
really scared me cuz they no November oh
is about to go oh yeah they give us a
whole week before Call of Duty comes out
let's go we can get through that real
quick ocp ocp
yeah cap that's look good it looks said
I'll buy that for a
dollar I'm pH technical director okay
and I'm
play it's very puzzle heavy y' very
puzzley so shaded can help you as you
progress so we excited they still got
some things I for them to work on but if
you like Puzzles they got puzzles Fe
they got puzzles out the
WOAY that dude just disappeared I ain't
like
that I ain't like that that technical
issue yeah I just saw him disappear that
a technical issue yeah the black guy
just disappeared yeah what's up with her
nose though why why do she look like
what's that dude
um oh man he's in Loki he plays uh morus
I
can't that nose is
wicked like the no that's crazy he said
Owen Wilson got the Owen Wilson
nose wison yeah this definitely a Game
Pass o o
spiders spiders had the shiny
butts why is she riding the
tornado love a woman that can ride a
tornado P lot of combat very puzzle
heavy her run is wild yeah little slow
pick
that they noses is
crazy
not how that other lady knows had to
crumple skelson like this dude right
here they nose game is
crazy they got a diverse palet of
noses you
stupid pick your nose
baby your man NOS is nuts definitely art
sty Chase
yeah they went nose
[Laughter]
[Music]
heavy yeah see you later see you later
you better be in gay oh man you better
be a gay y better not skip that back
they knock at your door you better
answer oh man don't do it like you
better pick up the
phone you ridiculous
[Laughter]
footage oh ever
wild yeah they changed the game a lot of
this that I know
right sted with a bird this time
ooh yeah set it on fire Odin's
eye yeah look like some North lithology
oh oh Fox man it look a fox or Elf oh
Fox that's a fox with a white tail
that's a white tail white tail
fox white wing
Crow oh man what buddy cop mov4 for
let's go man buddy only thing missing
now for him to claim he's going to buy
is a Ninja on it yeah all we need is
ninja that's it we lit cuz that's the
foxes from
go something happen
this what's going going on Spirit wait
on the
switch two part two
part section for Cog second from the
switch okay they better not miss the
phone call either you
stupid ask Cog did he play the first one
I know noock no more I never play I just
I wasn't capping for it I just said it
look cool this is our partner preview
say and this is
over gab be just hurt
they coming out thank you you a Sol 15
minutes and that's it if they rap
credits so far King so far King get a
zero out of 10
yo why we getting a recap already black
it's a black screen
it's come out it's stepping up relax
manal gear Snake Eater man okay okay in
engines relax I'm about to say you about
to get this work thank you
dat and Game Pass we got to see about
that but that look phenomenal yeah relax
wow that looks phenomenal look at that
that's crazy the most powerful console
on
Earth chicken let's get the chicken
going yo I ain't going to lie Snake
Eater was my best one mhm pop him you
saw that right they they they they
didn't want you to see him pop that
noodle man but we know the noodle is pop
that's right I just want to hear the oh
grab them shake them up pull them in the
bushes look at that Dynamic lighting
that R Trace look at that oh
crabs Mr
crabs
crabs you got the formula to the Krabby
Patties you don't stink
eater you got the jiger they got rats
crabs
buzzards fresh alligator
snout I like the fact that you can cook
them all up everything you saw there is
edible I see they didn't I see they fix
the animation on that
that
ior's mouth with like yeah some people
still little stiffy stiff it's still a
little stiff in
there stiffy stiff they said it's
character mhm look good though Slavic
magic okay what we got going on here
working
magic this looks very RT I see you know
what this is get him in the circle stab
up they got
knock as
his oh man this like f Brothers but me
medieval times now they now they took
the call out coming to PC G exclusively
PC not
you yeah definitely RTS oh it's
definitely build a road that you can let
the mooses go
through is it mooses or
Musa
M give me a couple of M this might M I
ain't going to lie this might actually
get me I like I'm a big silly bilder
person so that's what's up you m the to
Ming with the sky yeah day one yes now
he going he going to build a little
Mormon sky right here the show him the
like the Civil part now
some oh they they they you saw him right
some they going to ra your
to yeah this where the pill go
down
pillage fire fire on the PX fors where's
it at yes plant your
flag never
forget get the stab on this the seiz
them
section okay
okay we Endor this you see the Lords the
Lords Endor this Endor oh okay thank you
cuz you can't have a a Xbox preview of
it and this is a it's coming soon the
console don't worry we got thank you for
that we got you we got you don't worry
about that cool cool check out scan the
QR code to watch the interview
interesting click on
it I guess it's how to get real
engagement wow noodle
poppers noodle poppers are you ready
watch
The Welcome to the
finals oh the finals is finally coming
out what's this oh this is a big game
it's it's the game that the the
battlefield developers of working on
yeah multiplayer yeah multiplayer player
game only yeah Lead You In The City hit
you with the nitty this the battlefield
developer oh that looking good I like
that little um what you call it yeah oh
they knock coins out your behind man
this looks so Co de man I know a lot of
I know a lot of people that's been
playing this man yo you can bust and
D I'll play this I'll try it yo we in
this oh and the worlds is breaking up
look at that look at the destructibility
Levolution you can tell it's Battlefield
yeah Battlefield oh yeah they using
heavy crowd heavy crowd I me that's
cloud cloud heavy
Cloud this this is this looks crazy I
know man a three game show blow up D
Joy set him on and set him on fire set
him on
fire
why you kill I love that I love that we
didn't knock the coins out of here we're
able to do that kind of stuff cuz we we
we we funded correctly that's right
heavily funded coins knocked out I like
the baseball bat yeah I ain't going to
lie can you get the B can you reach the
finals the
finals the finals hilarious join the BET
join the BET oh so it's it's finally
going to be an open Beta coming up
finally it's been for a long oh what's
this oh this is the arc Arc that's
that's the P de man oh he be going crazy
right there y Dez they finally did your
game proud bro yeah Graphics y'all they
got graphics finally we don't got box
characters no more exactly we knew the
game only the only thing holded it up
what's that the disz pizzle in the water
who
time it ain't Sunday going wild crazy Ro
got you in the back of the scalp that's
super
effective much as I I'm not Ary it is
huge it look dope it look good I wonder
if it's AR two or yo remember that time
they capture fat boy and threw him down
inside the well and was throwing dooo on
him stupid if you see Vin Diesel you
know it's two yeah you know it's two
what if they remake one yeah maybe it's
a AR one remake oh yeah I'll be down for
that
[Music]
mhm cuz Vin Diesel was asking for too
much
money they just cut his behind
out he's like but we're family you
should pay
me that's
crazy yo yo they got rocket launch they
got CH to turn to to a horse back what's
going on that's how this game is this
game is
wild this should be an exclusive Phil
Spencer skin with the rocket on it side
on the show you saw that dude do that in
the um Forge right yeah this should be
huge they go hard for this is a oh they
got Kong this is on
game
yeah is crazy so oh it looks like part
one remastered right no that's two
Let's see we going to
see surval survival ascended so yeah
maybe it is the uh remastered one yeah
it look it looked like it's remastered
or maybe that's the new name I don't
have no idea art community no this epic
remake yes yes thank you y catch good
catch good catch so they remade the
first yeah that was my complaint yeah
they had to get them graphic up now to
gra what the hell is this to the why
they strap naked down
to it look like it
EP I see that I
see I see only 18% of the populace is
excited about
this and I actually like Allan Wake man
it's just too much stuff this month a
lot of stuff I need to escape this
nightmare female body inspector mhm
story I used to have that shirt in high
school work for the FBI sure shirt in
high school do boo yeah female body
inspector I'm done custom custom made
with the badge I would like you to put
your hands on the
wall the Lord do not
condone hey man behavior that's when New
York was stopping fris
heavy I had to ban that policy I was
upset yo oh wow
oh why is Keana reave in every
game listen why
not him though says I love you
too
yo crazy it's a good it's always been a
good looking game hell yeah this engine
looks nuts
this is like this week right next week
next week
October oh no that's this week that's
this week every time I see that game it
always just makes me wonder like how
great control to going to be when they
finally bring it out here we
go oh come on man page says the record
will open the overlap come on man or is
the predetermining it that's how I'll be
in my house when the lights go out
I get that little flashlight like a come
on man man man how big is this
house or this that's a school something
yeah it's something else yeah something
else N N N I got to play that with my
girl oh oh
no we're good we are good
oh add going to review this yo look at
the one walking on the hands oh man do
she
just oh man let's yo what oh
Lord got you got you I knowe it got you
got you you better put that fire lighter
in the
eyeball there a whole CP going in this
woman oh no no no no she can't see me in
the light yeah I'm about to say pull out
the big
gun yeah behind you
baby you hear her
mhm restless dream oh man this look
this got you again you better [__] her
man how you going to know where she is
still get snatched up get snatched
up there we go there we go see man at
this point man it's time to go time to
go out the window or something there got
to be a boss
fight man don't trust her shoot her
again mhm take her
wallet wallet she got that ghost
dollar
damn it's been a lot of time on this
yeah this we almost over this the finale
they like we going to give you the last
3 minutes
here the song will show me the way oh
look at the mirror let's
go I don't know this song but it sound
good
they said it was only a half an hour
yeah
okay so I'm going to hit somebody in my
DMs and smack them
around [__] oh somebody ke got some
misinformation yeah
Cann news they going to have to get that
man his
shield
we was outside hands on play as the new
character Saga we played as the new
character s find out more on the white
where are
you oh yeah now yeah now that's that's
the
[Music]
finale well we already know Allan Wake
is not in Game Pass yeah a lot of them
stuff is not in Game Pass yeah still
wakes the Deep RoboCop for me car
Robocop Robocop going to be that deal
can't wait for that this was a hard
six
yeah six no no C
remember other platforms I mean should
be Lear that according to rul it's a
zero yeah according to the rules six
they showed up where the other guys show
oh so we get points for show for tenis
we ain't going to we ain't going we new
thing okay point forend oh it's a
different day okay day hey hold on I
gotta switch my camera off okay mess
with
you I see what you're trying to do I
ain't gon to let you do it I'm just
saying I mean I'm just saying I'm just
saying nothing people go hard at the
state of play yeah that was a state of
play that was a that was a Sony uh first
party uh production so what we feeling
what we feeling y'all what's going six
all right I give it where we at six
six tell you where we
at uh you know when a dude tilt his head
to the side when
DT I mean I me what they gave me the
head to oh listen listen before before
they showed the finals it was a
four yeah yeah yeah it
was like RoboCop was the thing that was
holding it up and then you know I
already knew about the finals I just
didn't know they were going to show it
here I was like somebody get a [__]
Allan Allan you know what I can't I
can't get him a I can't I got to get I
my heart wants to give it a five but
Allan Wake does look really really good
and even though it's not a game that's
gonna be a Game Pass I know a lot of
people are going to be buying that so I
have to give it at least a six for at
least they they ended on they ended like
stronger but the beginning that thing
they could have kept they could have
kept most of that stuff yeah they they
they got to show they gotta show what
was that with big noos posy what was big
no
the only reason only reason I'm giving
them a six is because I do want them to
do more of these yes yeah I do too it's
just this one particularly didn't do
nothing for me I didn't even care about
somebody did have a secret show though
right yo you
stupid that is true they they did they
did drop this out of nowhere yeah yeah
always want shows but for me it didn't
I'm kind of six energy normally they
shut it down close this this close to
the holidays and they just talk about
the games that you know already came out
or things that's getting ready to come
out in the future but to drop it in no
drop it right towards the end of October
to let you kind of know what's coming up
in then literally in the next week or so
yeah two days yeah yeah that's really
cool that's really cool like yo Alan
Wake is not getting any love nobody's
pre-ordering like they supposed to uh
look at
it okay ever noticed the past couple
events a lot of the stuff isn't in Game
Pass it anymore cuz it used to be
everything in every event was in Game
Pass but I've noticed they've kind of
like went away from that a little bit
you know what I think and I'm glad you
pointed that out um what I think on
their main shows those will be like a
Game Pass section right and the fact
that they got all these Studios now Game
Pass is not going to be heavily relying
on third party Studio stuff inside game
because the first party is is so big now
so robust so now they can really pick
and choose instead of just running out
there and trying to grab everybody for
Game Pass yeah now I thought um a like I
said partner show expected third party I
only only thing I was disappointed
because I'm so used to it is at least
like a one or two surprise Game Pass
announcement attachment to any of these
big titles which we didn't see but um
I'm listen I'm happy they did a show I
mean at the end of the day we're still
excited that they did something but I'm
not going to be like yo this was crazy
like this is got theal okay cool
you know what I'm say RoboCop look
phenomenal I like the um the finals game
that look cool you know kind
of show we here we out here they they
they had some big ticket items Big
Ticket items like the show I like that
um PC game pass got some love yeah uh
Arc look good Arcy uh what that looks
good I'm Not Gon I can't I can't lie
that Arc finally for the people that
like Arc and and love their world
without even switching over to Arc to
let's just remake what you got real
quick before I will say I didn't as a
person who is a huge like a dragon fan I
didn't like you like what they show that
showing because it's like you you're GNA
misre represent people who don't know
about that game is gonna think yo this
is the core gameplay you were on the
island building stuff and it's like yeah
that might be a separate game entirely
though I don't know yeah it feels like a
separate mode but it's just that we know
that but I got to say I love that game
because they showed me on the beach so I
I really got some yeah all I was saying
you could show that Bo you ain't got to
just show only that and none of the core
stuff that people know they didn't even
show none of the turn base in it really
yeah like the stuff that people know the
game for so that that was my only thing
like why did they choose that but what
it is I I feel like the best showing
there was that the finals like yeah
finals is probably the best Robocop and
the finals were the strongest didn't
even do nothing for me really it was
just kind of good it it it is what it is
RoboCop is that is that juice no but for
him I I get it for ad because he doesn't
have remember we're attached to the
Nostalgia of a movie from our time
period you know what I'm saying so for
him he's like what's this that y'all
going crazy for I can get it I get it
who's this stiff who's this stiff dude
with a robot and Murphy and n29 what he
they talking about you know what I'm
saying I get his perspective but U no
that's it that's what I met so like I
said six for me I can't really give no
no higher than that but it would have
got higher for me if they would have
this would be being greedy if they' have
snuck in some yo Allan Wake Shadow Game
Pass drop yo infinite well I actually I
thought that was happening with f weight
CU it just it's like why are you going
to show a launch trailer to a game
coming out in two days in two yeah two
days in two days that that would have
been crazy but that nah I I can see that
I can see saying that I I think the show
would have been dope if they would have
did what I thought they was going to do
what you thought they was what you don't
happening so um I'mma out you I'mma out
you right now out affiliate is getting
outed I gotta out for bad reporting um
you hit me in the DM you told me that uh
you know because Rockstar put up a
unlisted video and um oh no they was
talking about te two was going to be
here I think people starting to realize
K will
[Laughter]
roll that sauces out the field said take
two it's going to be yeah I I thought I
thought it was supposed to be the Grand
Theft photo 6 I thought I thought they
was going to show that there to blow
people back out pa um I thought it was
that's why I brought the shield that's
why I brought the sh that's why that's
why the shield was out because y' for
Destruction y'all would have needed a
shield this is a real Joy this is the
real Shield y'all King needs sh King
needs to Shi yo GTA 6 would have broke
the
internet that would have been crazy know
um I'm calling the aerial strike on my
man um yeah
coordinates
77 they gave the wrong information set
set up yeah send it hey hey call 98%
Rate rates
going wait wait time out time out time
out that affects your 98% score about
that don't affect anything that affects
your average that was information that I
gave up I didn't predict a thing all
right that is true that is true stood on
that list you stood on Dragon Balls
pause so that's how you but but you did
yeah you did go out there and say this
was definitely going to happen we got to
come at you cuz at this the state of
plays you wear extra hard nothing is D
somebody else
y That's somebody else
that's was some El let me talk about
let's go let cuz Y come me right we G to
be fair all right all right first of all
this was a third party showcase they
told you that from the rip wasn't a
first party either that they literally
said our third no don't don't don't do
that um don't do that they I don't care
what they literally said it literally
say we going let we going to let him
Rock we going to let him Rock Let's Hear
This it literally said state of play
let's let's they third part they did
they have first party games in that
state of play yes they did okay fair
fair fair so over
here where they told you this is a third
party showcase expectation was set right
they was like yeah this is the preview
of what our third parties friends are
doing doing he's doing a very good job
tucking and yeah these are
associates they said these are
Associates of us that
yoing King King is rolling more than
Nathan Drake does in the whole game he
is right with the but it's a lot of
rolling it's a lot of now you going sit
you sitting there who who that creeping
into your shot
ad he's kind of scared the hell out
of that's what I thought I watch your
back so I'm thinking on state of play
like everybody said ghost to Shima all
this stuff
what they did they did show some they
try to be slick they try to hide their
BS Microsoft said n these are my mans
and
them light you know saying like these my
peoples I know them they like to spit so
I'm let them do their thing over Mike
night for that's what that's what we got
night all right but my DM the DM was
like yo it's supposed to be XY and Z so
I'm really going to Str if I can
strangle you
bro it because it was just my
expectation my expectation of it was
like really high but at the same time
I'mma say this right I'mma say it to any
Sony detractor any dude out there this
is damage control right now n no n this
is this is not damage control where the
hell is your show at any show friendly
show unfriendly show Y show maybe a show
Secret show how many times I got to hear
Secret Show and Microsoft said hold on a
second I got you since they keep holding
y'all telling y'all it's going to be a
secret show I gotve that Microsoft gave
them microphones and say yo I can spit
over here y'all spit it cuz we got a
stage go out there do your thing and
left not one Microsoft game there cuz it
wasn't about them it was about their
friends so let their friends do their
thing so when you want to judge it as a
Microsoft show no but judge it as a
friend show cuz our friends like to got
they got Gams too our friends got so so
so when son came out said this is a
third party state of play and you see
where was that energy where was that
this is our friend show yo when they say
it's a third party show then we then
don't call it a state of play stop
giving up
expectations a third party show that's
what it's got right call do what
Microsoft just did our friends and
them he just told he just told us don't
count unless they it don't matter if
they're very transparent that it's a
third party show he K King King is like
don't call a state of plate this this
was not King is going to Blockbuster
picking a game out just off of the cover
thinking they looking bad look great
plays it he like this is trash you got
you didn't read nothing you going to
hate them for not reading that listen
first of all that's misrepresentation I
need I need that Meme from The Simpsons
was the
SED to read not you trying to duck and
Dodge the Fate you can't duck and Dodge
the Fate if it's called a state of play
and they have first party games it was
no first party game it wasn't even no
games for Game Pass here I was eled to
leave not to read go you you just trying
to mince the words about it it's it is
how you fool the public the public
wasn't fooled here cuz they told you now
this is my friends and them um we not
going to be there so they did I say we
are not going to be what crazy is not
one person from Microsoft face showed up
it was nobody talking about nothing they
they was just like games games games
curiosity yeah why did you think they
were gonna be there before the
show well
now I yo first of all I've never seen
them do a show like this I've never seen
no one come out they did they did
remember the first third party showcase
that we actually liked right was right
around launch time and that was the one
where they had EXO Mecca that never came
out I'm still waiting for you know what
I'm saying with the Dinobots in the
joint that joint was a third party joint
where it was just like trailer trailer
that's what we saw bright memory
infinite right we saw scorn right um
that one I liked you know what I'm
saying it was like I like that show too
and they didn't really show nobody come
out if I don't remember I don't remember
like I had to check that show again but
I think they started off with this is a
show for our friends yeah yeah third
party in they s expectation but I think
somebody came out and was like yo this
was that and I also remember a lot of
those games was like Game Pass or
something like that right right it was
more Game Pass and the only criticism
they got for that one was that they were
like um people wanted more gameplay as
opposed to cinematic trailer but we
actually me and yuk King we love that
show we actually thought it was a solid
show you know what saying kind of thing
but I I get where you're going on it
does literally does say the partner
showcase I get get that part and it kept
saying it this is the partners preview
but we have to ad it was it was you know
average to above average at no it's a
six okay okay no I'm not I'm not I'm not
giving it more than a six the only
reason why I was knocking the Sony show
was one they showed Spider-Man one they
two they showed a final
fantasy you gotta also remember it's a
state of play right so your your your
thing is they should stop saying state
of play cuz the expectation is isy and
then when Okay so what was the game with
the the naked dude with the what was it
baby oh you talking about baby steps
yeah that's what you was upset you oh
man now that right there was kind of
crazy um but and but that's day joint
ain't baby steps day joint I I don't
remember I don't I think that came in
wasn't that Naughty Dog what that was
not naughty stop stop wait wait wait
wait what n that was a fire Sprite fire
Sprite doing that other game um they
showed hell divers they was really
trying to make y'all believe a lie so
Forte have we confirmed cuz me and AD
have to get disagre have we confirmed
that it didn't say a straight to play
third party though have we confirmed
that because that that's the key that if
they said third party then nobody Ain
read but they show first party stuff
they did they did yeah so no it was a
state of play and it got judged how it
got J okay so you said because they say
St play they got to get the smoke to be
fair to be fair we we we have known the
the uh state of play uh the showcases to
be the stuff that's really their stuff
like that was a showcase wasn't that
chill why they calling you Benedict
Forte what is going on what did I miss
what is happening Forte what is
happening why are they calling you that
what's coming on it it was it was a
showcase was it a lot of things oh is
this where they was clipping you and
they was say like using oh oh they still
on you for they still on me man they
still on
me they owe me for having they owe me
for being upset at Xbox for a while oh I
remember because they okay cuz they
having a good year now there people mad
at you I was like listen man that's fine
they can come they feel that's where you
at with it right you just you you you
not happy just yet you want to see more
that's oh I'm fine now I just I wasn't
happy earlier this year and last year
fair enough fair enough 2022 get these
super chats real quick let's get the
Super Chat get super we got roll up out
here member of Flores bronze from mighty
mellow $2 Super Chat from Cory Tidwell
congrat uh congrats adct sounds like you
having a baby on the way okay $5 from
God Soul no
ps6 Jesus facts let's say that again got
a gifted uh membership from uh Craig
hooligan appreciate that $5 Super Chat
from Cory Tidwell King about to Hype up
these exclusive mesh shaders in Island
wake got a $2 Super Market IOP the
entertainers let's have fun yes sir got
a $5 Super Chat from Michael Mooney
where's my Robocop versus
Terminator got only that did that I love
that comic book combat was the only one
that actually you could kind of have
that fight yeah no they got a comic book
Robocop versus Terminator yeah told me
right kind of BM that uh that uh bers
Gate 3 Xbox didn't get announced yeah
what do you think will be released
November
December at this point but they
said like they said a l SE September to
November yeah it be out that would have
been a good look I I like that Super
Chat you right I wish it was if it was
ready that would have been a nice n they
said they didn't want to associate they
s with that show they didn't Nintendo
theu with the $5 Super C they showed an
animal crossing mode for infinite wealth
it's going to be the bestselling game of
the franchise he may be right look he
may was on if it was on Nintendo it
definitely would be look it the mold may
be fire I just feel that as as such a
fan of that franchise if someone never
saw infinite wealth for the first time
and they saw that they make think that's
the game and I don't want them to be
like that this is a extra mold you know
what I'm saying that's all I'm trying to
say in his game yeah like you they got
my man out here vacationing doing a side
project he building
and they like oh that's what your man
did I was going to ask you to K I said a
person that puts a 100 hours in that
game how do you feel about the way they
show I did not like the way they show
first they show him naked then they show
him riding
Dolphins the only reason why I'm about
that game because they had me on the
beach look I'm a huge ity the C of you
guys are coming for me c Forte like they
are like your man's a clown which he is
he's always been a clown but he's The
Lovable idiot you know what I'm saying
that's why I like him and his game is
better but that's not his game this is a
they they they making so much money they
like yo let's make an animal crossing
baby it's crazy you know what I'm saying
they they getting the Nintendo bag they
getting the Nintendo bag that's what
they
doing switch to launch title2 from John
Wolf PlayStation had a state of Crisis
salute look oh wow $10 Super Chat from
Wonder hos Arc is out today apparently
oh day it's out on yeah it's out today
on PC they should have said that on the
they should have said that on the show
yeah no I even right said PC game pass
yeah I mean no no PC not PC game pass oh
I was about to say well then it's a lit
situation so Arc survival evolve dropped
today I guess yeah today yeah supposedly
today on PC and November and then
November and cons for console I do like
the fact that they all saying yo we
still coming to console y'all relax we
got we we ain't forgot about y'all yeah
that's for you go extra back slap with
the 40 uh he's been a member for 40
months he's got uh he said shout out to
Benedict Forte on the panel just
Benedict Forte that's crazy yo 900 of
y'all in the chat that's love that's
what's up this is a this is a random day
that's what's up Wednesday that's what's
up show the love got a $10 Super Chat
from the black
Viking uh PSA to chat hit the like And
subscribe yeah man hit that like hit
that like hit that like button y you
guys ain't going to want to miss Sunday
man I'm telling
you something for you baby especially
that stuff that David just leaked again
today yeah you don't want to miss that
yes uh5 um $5 Super Chat from Wonder hos
Arc is out on PC Today consoles in
November got a member chat been a member
for two months add 117 yako eight AKA
Sims to Cast Away going to be Game of
the Year
2024 Sony can keep they for uh foam
Stars PlayStation going to be an app TTS
King oh my
mess got a $5 subra from har Shen oh
Hy K you need to play the original KU
Yakuza
games kiru Y game Tran uh since it isn't
in the same timeline it's it's Game Pass
yeah yo you right Hari um the only thing
is I'm going to jump in with kiru at um
the man who erased his name because I
played that at Pax Wester that look fire
and I'm I'll do the recap from the I
don't like the old style beat him up but
the new style beat him up me oh you
don't like the one that's in Game Pass
right now no no now Ean what he talk
about they said it's at the same
timeline he's right I'm scared though
because it's like damn can I really
invest that much time in another you
know dra like a dragon game cuz Persona
tactics and um infinite I mean the man
who rac's name is coming back to back so
I I got to I got to space that we'll see
back definitely back to back but I'm
thinking about it but KIRO I'm gonna
give him his love on the man who erased
his name then we got a $2 super from Eli
it was announced a third party in the
Indie state of
play okay yeah he's talking why they
have first party games there what is
their first party games they Spider-Man
there um yeah I'm trying to remember
they have Spider-Man there yeah they did
have Spider-Man there yeah why they
showed that again yeah that's kind of
true that's kind of true why every time
they show it is no
bugs sorry I wouldn't play The Man Who
RAC as it's like Yakuza 7 for the kir
yeah I'm I'm good like I gotta say
Ichiban is my man I just want to know
why he here why is this other your old
hero here and this is the new hero he
gonna be my man sidekick I'm stop did
you just say he's gonna be the going be
my man the series has going on to
Greater Heights with Ich Bond so you
know you got to pay to the old the
former
Champion are we talking about the state
of play that was in
September I believe so yeah yeah they
show Spiderman they show Spider-Man 2
final that's first party Final Fantasy 7
rebirth they show deep uh deep Earth
collection they sh uh hell divers 2
Ghostbusters rise of the ghost Lord baby
steps ghost ghost Runner to fo and foam
star yeah they well they had some first
party did first party games thank you oh
and Tails yeah tals of arise too so yeah
they they they had a mix I don't that's
I don't really see how that's an indie
showcase yep right tell the truth Shane
the devil let it be a lot of that's a
lot of big games in that show yeah it is
like I said they be trying to bambooz
and Hood wi you dude you out of control
got a$ PI from uh drawn TJ all hell King
David no
ps6 that's right no ps6 we on that #
[Music]
no they mad at
me went so when's the trans when's the
transformation to the app gonna happen
it's gonna happen at the end of the
generation ain't gonna be nothing else
you already see everybody gone and
leaving stuff Rome is burning I mean do
you got to smell do you got to feel a
fire on your back like what do you I
mean oh you can smell it it's in the
air listen I we don't know what's
happening next year like really don't
but it's not they day today we don't
care to talk about them the Xbox pre our
third party our was friends it was the
friends in them show and the friends in
the friends in them show they get a hot
sex them the friends in them they came
out they performed for y'all I hope yall
like what the friends of them was doing
you gotta stop calling the friends of
them the friends and them had a great
show for them like so if liked anything
from the friends in them that would be
available on Xbox series X and S and you
can have fun with the friends and them
so later on you will have an Xbox show
where first party games will be shown
but today it was all about friends in De
you got to stop calling it that I don't
like that man you giving somebody a good
podcast name right there $2 super trap
uh Phil it be all hit me with the bag in
them too $2 Super Chat $2 Super Chat
Phil Spencer better throw that Connie
bag oh we got to talk about that yeah we
got we might have to reach out to um the
homie what's his face U jaffy we because
he got the exclusives on that he was on
cold last night Monday he was on cold on
Monday no but he broke more stuff today
he broke stuff he had some more stuff
happening yeah we need to have all right
but I think we we done we we what you
got to something do yeah he do you Ain
see somebody creeping in his his I
thought that was his I thought that was
his cat nah it was a whole
person yo it was bigger it was bigger
than the poster she's like you better
you you you done yet hold on let me get
that let me get it Luci I'm G bother the
K guy he said you don't understand k
kiro's goed I love ich kir still the
goat he may be the goat but he like rock
C's albums ain't sell no more so we were
n we would n Ichiban is the future your
man we he's going to be featured on the
track know he said he's like rockim his
albums don't sell anymore nobody they
buying them rockim joint you got now
they even
search triple wood out
G you got to pay for that's I say I said
I said Co they put one in Game Pass and
one in not game they said yo go listen
to rock him please go get it we got him
in Game Pass now you wasn't rocking with
him before hey wait wait time out wasn't
like a dragon launched and Game Pass no
it was paid they didn't it was so
popular that Sega said yo we got we we
love this we love this we I could have
swor that about
like that game was game it wasn't game
pass but not at launch it was a launch
title for the series X and then nobody
listened to his ball and the no they
bought the game love the game and it's
like yo we want to learn about Yakuza
she all right go go go get rock or
something yeah was outside baby
everybody likes my the Future No I know
he I know when he was on Soundcloud kiru
gotta paint his head and make himself
hot relevant with the young kids a
listening to him no more oh no wait wait
hold on hold on hold on I got wait wait
hold on it says yeah yeah yeah yeah paid
paid exact say it for T yeah you thought
you got me but I got you you got to pay
for my
and like ad said you going to pay for
infinite wealth cuz it's infinite wealth
over so but so when his album still slow
down listen it youit hit a rough patch
say put okay so I'll wait get a six
month I wait I'll wait for a couple of
months he be oh he definitely coming to
Game Pass he definitely coming to Game
Pass but I'm just mess with y' I love
KIRO I'm G I'm gonna play the games it's
just you know itchy bomb right there
that's he he got a little itchy bomb
flavor itchy B it are we good we caught
up yeah oh man that was all no doubt no
doubt good stuff y'all good to see y'all
in the real we we'll see you got Sunday
we got stuff to talk about man yes lot
of stuff to talk about all right y don't
want to see me Sunday y out let me see
who I'm gonna send you guys to who we
sending them to what we sending them to
um let's send the post up we ain't never
definitely oh post up got a lot of
information on there we going send you
guys post up go over there to uh to IOP
raid I raid I'mma look too I better see
some I raids in that chat go over there
and be like post up you know who send
you over here get that man sh no doubt
trouble shoot hard geek salute everybody
enjoy